أجنبي
، من السهل أن تسقط لأربعة من كلاب روتويللر الرائعة ،
لكن هذا هو نوع السقوط
الذي لا يكون محرجًا فقط عندما تكون
جزءًا من فيديو جرو لطيف للغاية ،
يصبح Wipeout مزحة عالمية
كان العالم بأسره يسخر
مني جيمس  كان فيليبسون كلبًا يجلس
أمام أخت زوجته التي تمتلك مورفيوس
ممفيس ميدوسا وميداس في مزرعة في
ولاية واشنطن ، إنهم
كلاب محبوبون للغاية ويريدون فقط أن يكونوا
أينما كنت طوال الوقت لذلك عندما
حاول جيمس الاحتفاظ بهم
داخل البوابة ظلوا يرغبون في
متابعته ذهابًا وإيابًا ، ركضوا ثم استدار آه ، لقد
ألقى جيمس باللوم
على عدم تنسيقه ، وقال إنه كان
مؤلمًا حقًا ، هل أنت بخير ، أعني
هل تأذيت لذا هذا هو الأسوأ لذلك
لم يكن الأمر سيئًا حقًا ،
فالقصة لديها جرو يبلغ من العمر 10 أسابيع ، يُدعى
ممفيس ،
هذا الجرو يريحني فقط ،
ثم يبدأ في الزحف بين
ساقيّ بعد ذلك ، يأتي مورفيوس ويسحب سلسلة القلنسوة الخاصة
به في النهاية جيمس
جر نفسه في وضع مستقيم واستأنف
محاولة حصاد الجراء في وقت من الأوقات
وألقي بأحدهم أشعر بالرهبة لأنني
عدت وأحب أن أعانق هؤلاء الجراء
أخيرًا تمكنت جليسة الكلاب من
إغلاق البوابة لتنتهي القصة
التي تركت جيمس بذيله  بين
ساقيه جعل ذلك
جينيموس البوب ​​CNN
نيويورك